[Applause]
hey everybody it is your friend josh and
i am here to tell you
i'm so excited for you to see this new
comedy clip but first
let me tell you about my friends from
raycon raycon is
disrupting the electronics industry
everybody if you are looking for the
best
earbuds in the game there's no doubt
that it's at raycon
now i can tell you about a ton of things
i can tell you about the six
hour play time i could tell you that my
boy mike tyson uses them i can tell you
that snoop dogg
uses them the colors the different sizes
come on everybody there's a 45 day
return policy guys it is all so good
they're revolutionizing the game half
the cost
but better value better quality but that
is not even my favorite part
about the ray j earbud raycon
experience guys if you're looking to
separate yourself from your screen
raycon and this is what i use them for
the best working out earbuds because
they fit your hole
you know how sometimes they slip out of
your hole you want things that fit your
hole
the raycon earbud fits in your hole
you click the link in the description
right where i'm fingering you right in
that box
go to buy recon dot com forward slash
josh wolfe it's all forward slashes now
you get 15 percent off
that is by raycon.com forward slash
josh wolf if you want to get all the
good stuff on there this is the best
earbud you are ever going to put
in your tiny little heart
at a point in time in my life guys i was
a single dad raising three kids
and um for those of you who have kids
you know that daycare is super expensive
and i was living in la i was living in
one room with the three kids i was
making 1200
a month which is i don't know what that
gets you in orlando but in la that gets
you
dick right as a matter of fact i don't
even think you can buy dick in la for
1200 so
um but i knew i was like i can't afford
to put them in daycare i need to make
money while they're at school
that's four hours a day at the time and
i was like okay what am i gonna do and i
was looking through looking through and
i found a job that said forty five
dollars an hour make your own hours and
i'm like
that's the job i need that's it so i
uh they say just come down for an
interview i put on a three-piece suit
i go down there i'm in the office i'm
talking to the guy
he asked me like three or four questions
and then he says to me he goes do you
have any idea
what this job is and i said i uh
do not and he said it's it's for phone
sex
he said do you have a problem with that
and i said i uh
do not
because look man i'm gonna tell you the
truth i'm not a good dirty talker and so
i was like i'm gonna learn a skill and
i'm not learning that devry i'll tell
you what the [ __ ] you know what i mean
i'm gonna learn a skill 45 an hour guys
i'm not lying at the time of the
interview i had 37
in my bank total for everything so i was
like this i'm gonna make more money
in an hour than i have and uh i told the
guy that i'm like i'm ready to start
today
and he goes really i go yeah i'd like to
start today and if you could pay me in
cash
and then you can take it off my check
but i need some money and he was like
yeah man i'll get you started and he
said i'll train you myself and i go okay
so he puts on one of those little you
know one of the [ __ ] nsync headsets
you know what i'm saying
like and um he walks out and he goes
here's a deal
first of all we're not going to use your
real name
let's go with steve i said okay and he
goes here's a couple things you need to
know
first thing you need to know is the way
the company makes money
is you keep them on the phone because we
charge by the minute
so when they you think they're going to
come don't let them come too fast
divert the longer you keep on the phone
the more money we make i go got it
and they said the way you make more
money is if they call
and ask for you so make their orgasm
memorable
and i was like got it and i'm just
walking through the office like my name
is steve
keep them on the phone make their orgasm
memorable
my name is steve keep him on the phone
make the orgasm memorable and then as
i'm turning the corner
i just hear this oh yeah
that makes me so wet and i was thinking
this job's gonna be [ __ ] awesome
i'm gonna get paid for this and i can't
wait to see who's there and i turned the
corner
expecting to see just this beautiful
woman
and it was like this 85 year old asian
woman
in an adidas tracksuit
[Laughter]
[Music]
and i turn the corner and i make eye
contact with her when she goes
touch my [ __ ] and i was like no
so i walk into my office
and i'm like oh my god right and the guy
goes all right here's the deal
i'm gonna sit in here with you um i'm
gonna sit behind you because i need to
know
what your style is uh he said but i i i
the guy i'll be able to talk to you and
you'll be able to hear me but he won't
be able to hear me
and it'll just be me talking to you and
i said okay you're gonna sit behind me
and he goes yeah
and i go all right you know just don't
let your boner hit me in the back you
know what i mean
and he was like uh no problem
um and the phones light up and i go
which one you guys can pick any one
lucky number four and i'm like hey
this is steve and i hear hey
this is james and i go hold please
i said to the guy i think i think he's
got the wrong number
and he said what do you mean i go well
it's a dude and the guy who's training
me laughed he goes wait a second wait a
second wait a second
did you think women were going to call
you
[Laughter]
[Music]
and i said yeah right he goes no dude
this job is dicks for days like you're
you're not going to
you're not going to hear one woman i go
are you sure he goes let me ask you
something
all the women you've ever met in your
life how many do you know that need to
call a phone sex line i'm like
none and he said add all the men how
many do you know would call a phone sex
line i'm like
every single one he was like that's
who's calling you he said is that going
to be a problem
and i said i don't know
i mean i've never jerked off a guy not
named josh before i don't know the
answer to that question
yeah you know and i need the money man i
got 37
i'm like ah and he said let me try to
help you he said i know you need the
money
but you have to do the job let me see if
i can help you he said are you an actor
and i said yeah
and he said great act your character's
name is steve
and i was like okay he goes does that
help and i said yeah he said great
and all you need to know about steve all
you need to know about your character
is that steve loves [ __ ] and i was like
i said yeah that's the part i'm bumping
up against i think yeah
and he i go i just don't know if i can
do it he goes what's the problem i go
boy they're gonna they're gonna
like orgasm in my ear right and he goes
yeah i go
ah
i don't think so i don't know and he
goes let me he goes you like prince and
i go yeah
he goes that dude's been coming in your
ear for 20 years like just
he said just pretend like his prince i'm
like well that's kind of hot all right
here we go
uh and he was like he was like look you
want to keep doing it
yeah let me let me keep doing it he goes
all right get in there i go don't say
that
[Laughter]
and i get back on the phone i go hey
sorry about that james i had to run
upstairs and he goes yeah me too i had
to run up to the bedroom i go okay
and uh before i could say anything
he goes uh because james was
ready to get right into it i just hear
on the other line he goes hey i just
want you to know
that my [ __ ] is rock hard right now
and i said
i said i said
what
and he goes my [ __ ] is rock hard right
now i go
yeah i guess i heard you the first time
uh
and he goes do you want to touch it and
the guy with a headset on goes
so i go
sure
[Laughter]
and then i go
i don't know how to play with a [ __ ] on
the phone everybody like i don't [ __ ]
know what noise i'm supposed to make
that's not my wheelhouse you know what
i'm saying i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm doing
but and the guy in my ear goes all right
now you got it
you got you're in his pants get out
divert divert divert now this was years
ago in l.a right and then
the lakers were big and i go hey man i
go before we go any further i go what do
you think about kobe bryant
and the guy goes james goes i would
totally [ __ ] him i go that's not what i
thought you were gonna say at all
and i gotta i gotta tell you for for a
minute there no matter what i said to
this dude he everything he brought back
to his dick
and for a second i think i kind of know
what it likes feels like to be a woman
because
no matter what i said he was like what
about my dick
at one point i was like hey man what
about a movie he goes can i bring my
dick i'm like do you usually leave it at
home [ __ ] like what
i was like what the [ __ ]
so and before i can get back into it
right the guy
james goes hey i go yeah and he goes uh
you know what feels really good right
now i go what's that
and he goes if you kiss it he goes you
wanna kiss it
and the guy in the headset goes
so i go i go
sure
so i'll just go and he goes that feels
so good
and i gotta tell you guys if you told me
the day before that i was gonna fake
blow a dude on the phone
and he was gonna compliment me and i was
gonna feel good about it i would have
told you you're [ __ ]
up but i gotta tell you it was such a
stressful day and i needed the job so
badly
when he said that feels good you know
what i said thank you
i really i i've been working hard today
this is a tough job i'm glad you
and he goes you want to kiss it again i
go you know i do
right
and then he goes he goes i'm ready to
orgasm do you want to orgasm with me
and i go sure and this is how james
orgasms everybody ready oh i heard it
you have to
[Laughter]
james goes uh
it was like jerking off michael buffer
the ring announcer ah
let's get ready to come back
so he starts to go ah and the guy in my
ear was like you gotta do it with him
i'm like ah
and the guy my ears like make him
memorable i'm like oh my god and james
goes ah
so i just screamed get some
[Laughter]
i got fired um
yeah apparently the guy was like yeah
you don't scream get some i'm like all
right well
and he paid me 45 which i spent on
tequila and wheat
[Music]
[Music]
you